[Musique]
Pierre Laurent sénateur de Paris ESR
international du Parti communiste
français et l'invité de preuve par 3
bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous pour en fait le dernier des
rendez-vous consacrés à l'élection
sénatoriale de dimanche et pour cause
hein le scrutin donc maintenant a lieu
dans dans quelques jours mais bien sûr
pierrelaurent l'actualité nous amène
hélas à d'autres questions la gravité de
la situation bien sûr après l'exécute
l'exécution du guide de montagne Hervé
Gourdel en Algérie assassiné parce que
français a souligné François Hollande
oblige à l'unité national même si vous
exprimez des réserves sur la guerre
menée contre le groupe qui se présente
comme l'état islamique mais n'est-ce pas
ce dernier qui décide de mener la guerre
à l'Occident en recourant à l'horreur
barbare vous allez vous expliquer sur ce
point Pierre-Laurent avec moi ce soir
Catel prigan de l'Agence France Presse
notre partenaire comme chaque semaine de
preuve par 3 et bien sûr pint Tarnaud de
Public Sénat et à la fin de cette
émission donc on parlera du Sénat qui
sans doute va basculer à droite dimanche
tous les drapeaux vont être mis en berne
en France pendant 3 jours annonce de
François Hollande les événements et la
menace où nous sommes donc où
sommes-nous en sécurité aujourd'hui euh
comme français oblige à bien sûr à
serrer les tous derrière le chef de
l'État je je crois qu'il y a deux choses
il faut serrer les rangs contre autour
de la famille d'Hervé
Gourdel parce que ce crime parfaitement
odieux est inacceptable et je pense
soulève l'horreur de tous nos
compatriotes et bien au-delà et donc
j'ai dit dès hier ma ma solidarité
entière avec la famille et et ses
proches euh ensuite il y a face à l'état
islamique il faut agir oui c'est ce que
fait la France le débat porte justement
sur la bonne manière d'agir nous ne
sommes pas la situation actuelle ne
tombe pas du ciel c'est ces chosesl ont
commencé il y a maintenant plus de 10
ans avec l'attentat du 11 septembre et
il nous menons soi-disant l'Occident
mène la guerre au terrorisme depuis 10
ans il faut faire le bilan contestz vous
contestez ce point mais le bilan c'est
que ces groupes n'ont cessé de se
développer et que toutes les opérations
militaires qui ont été menées en anistan
qui ont été menés en IR qui ont été
menés en Libye ce solde par une
aggravation de la situation la
déstabilisation Comat de longue Alline
d'ailleurs tout le monde s'accorde
là-dessus ça sera long oui c'est un
combat de longue haleine mais surtout je
pense qu'il prend une mauvaise direction
nous nous ne mettons pas en œuvre les
moyens de lutte efficac contre ces
groupes et il y a beaucoup de choses à à
mettre sur la table qui ne le sont pas
ces groupes ont été à des moments aidés
par un certain nombre de puissances
internationale ou de puissance régionale
parce que on a on a pensé pouvoir en
faire des des des combattants au service
des intérêts occidentaux et puis
finalement aujourd'hui les monstres
échappent à ceux qui les ont créés donc
il faut s'interroger sur ça et sur le
rôle ambigu joué par certaines
puissances de la région nous sommes nous
sommes responsables de la lutte qui est
menée contre nous mais je je pense que
la guerre américaine en Irak qui a
déstabilisé ce pays qui a répandu les
armes qui a les États-Unis ont soutenu
pendant 8 ans une gestion du pays en
Irak qui a abouti à la dislocation de ce
pays qui a communautarisé ce pays on a
soutenu le régime turc qui faisait la
guerre aux forces Kurdes alors qu'on
voit aujourd'hui que ces forces Kurdes
que nous soutenions pour notre part
parce que ce sont des forces
démocratiques on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui
qu'elles sont nécessaires pour faire
alors il faut pas oublier l'histoire
Pier sû y a beaucoup de questions à
poser il a des questions
ce sont des questions pour le passé là
aujourd'hui il y a un consensus
international on le voit à l'ONU pour
roster à la barbarie qui se met en place
oui mais encore
fautan encore faut-il trouver trouver
les moyens et efficace de cette lutte
parce que à chaque fois je rappelle
qu'en Libye quand nous sommes allés nous
sommes intervenus en Libye c'était au
nom du même argument le résultat c'est
qu'on a on a on a tué kadfi si on a
éliminé son régime mais on a transformé
ce pays en chaos total on n rien géré
derrière et maintenant tout le monde le
dit il y a des des armes en quantité
industrielles qui circulent dans ce pays
et la Libye est devenu un endroit où ces
groupes viennent chercher des armes pour
les emmener qu'est-ce qu' fait je suis
votre démonstration Pierre Laurent il y
a aujourd'hui malheureusement des jeunes
français des compatriotes qui s'engagent
dans le djihad en Syrie vous dites que
c'est nous aussi qui les avons enfant
mais c'est c'est c'est nous la logique
de guerre ils s'en nourrissent il faut
bien voir ça ce sont des groupes qui
veulent la guerre et qui veulent la
militarisation de tous les conflits donc
quand il y a eu un conflit par exemple
en Syrie quand le peuple syrien s'est
soulevé contre la dictature de Bachar
el-Assad et que Bachar el-Assad a
employé la répression contre les forces
démocratiques il ne fallait pas aller à
la militarisation croissante du conflit
il fallait au contraire réunir
l'ensemble des pays de la planète pour
imposer des solutions politiques vers
une transition démocrati donc
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui que l'on parle
de guerre le mot maintenant il est
clairement prononcé vous dites il ne
faut pas faire cette guerre il ne faut
pas en rajouter sur l'escalade militaire
parce queut direo par exemple les fr
est-ce que les frappes aériennes est-ce
que les frappes aériennes qui sont mené
actuellement par la France en Irak et
par les États-Unis en Syrie vont
empêcher ce qui s'est passé
hier en Algérie qu par exemple à
l'évidence non donc Siou quand par
exemple on bombarde les camp quand comme
la nuit dernière en Syrie des
raffineries sont bombardées qui
permettent aujourd'hui à l'état
islamique de se financer d'acheter des
par exemple qui mais qui achète le
pétrole desits qui sont sous le contrôle
aujourd'hui de l'État islamique pourquoi
est-ce que des puissances avec lesquels
nous travaillons des puissances
régionales continuent d'acheter le
pétrole à ses puits c'est ça qui Richi
c'est parce que ils extraient du pétrole
mais ils le vendent à des pays ils le
vendent dans le monde alors par exemple
interdisons des des crétons que plus
personne n'achète de pétrrole au pétrole
qui sont contrôlés par marchés de la
contrebande hein alors c'est plus
compliqué encore vous savez on on on
nachète pas les gens qui qui contrôlent
le marché des produits pétroliers dans
le monde ne sont pas des gens qui se
promènent avec des jicanes sous le bras
sont des États qui sont derrière le
commce du pétrole je vous demandais tout
à l'heure on sert les rangs derrière le
chef de l'État vous me dites NON même
s'il dit que la guerre est une nécessité
elle répond à l'honneur de du pays que
la France que la France soit unie je le
répète derrière la famille que les
drapeaux
soient ça me paraî Absolum normal ça me
paraît absolument normal et cette unité
nationale oui mais qu'on nous demande
pas au nom de cela de taire le débat qui
existe sur la manière dont nous menons
la efficacement ou pas la guerre sur le
contre terrorisme en irac ce débat tout
le monde est d'accord hein pour
l'aborder pour dire queeffectivement les
frappes ne suffiront pas et qu'il faudra
bien sûr l'œuvre de la diplomatie de la
persuision auprès de certains pays
arabes qui d'ailleurs participent à la
coalition internationale oui mais il
reste que nous sommes que nous sommes
engagés pour le moment dans une
coalition qui est dirigée par les
États-Unis qui a été décidé au sommet de
l'OTAN à Newport début septembre nous
sommes embarqués une nouvelle fois dans
cette dans ces opérations militaires
sans véritablement contrôler les buts de
guerre donc la France doit retrouver à
la remorque des États-Unis mais encore
une fois la coalition est internationale
oui enfin elle est internationale elle a
été décidée au sommet de l'OTAN si on
voulait si on veut un cadre multilatéral
efficace il faut faire à nouveau jouer à
l'ONU son rôle or on laisse décliner le
rôle de l'ONU et on le remplace de plus
en plus par l'OTAN pour conduire ces
opérations or on sait que l'OTAN n'est
pas à même
de rassembler dans un un dialogue
politique et des solutions diplomatiques
l'ensemble des forces qui doivent être
impliqué la solution alors est-ce que
vous simplement vous refusez le le droit
au chef de l'État à François Hollande de
décider souverainement de bombarder
l'IRAC Pier Laurent mais je la
Constitution permet aujourd'hui au chefs
de l'état de décider seule une
opération mais je pense que au niveau de
gravité parce que je prends la mesure de
la gravité de la situation au niveau de
la gravité de la situation actuelle je
pense par exemple je je je l'ai dit hier
au Sénat qu'il aurait été normal de
débattre au Parlement avant d'engager
ses opérations militaires alors on on
peut me rétorquer que la Constitution
permet d'agir comme le fait le chef de
l'État c'est vrai c'est simplement le
signe que cette constitution est à mes
yeux anachronique par rapport à
l'ampleur des problèmes qu'on a à traité
il faudrait restaurer la voix du
Parlement réellement le Parlement
aujourd'hui est une chambre p
consultative sur ces enjeux de guerre
alors que nous sommes maintenant engagés
dans plusieurs théâtres d'intervention
militaire dans plusieurs guerres en
Afrique au Moyen-Orient en Libye et tout
ça se fait sans que le Parlement na
jamais en décidé alors le combat semaine
aussi nous l'avons dit en France avec le
retour des djihadistes de Syrie hélas
les les exemples ne manquent pas et on
ne comprends pas vraiment la position du
Parti que que vous dirigez puisque vous
avez dit oui à la Assemblée nationale
aux mesures qui ont été présenté par par
le gouvernement et et le parti les
condamne vous vous ressortez la menace
de du patriotact américain c'est pas ça
nous condnons pas les députés les
députés de notre groupe à l'Assemblée
c'est un débat qui compliqué RA c'est
nous nous pensons qu'il existe
actuellement dans
l'arsenal juridique et policiers
français les moyens de contrôler ces
situations et nous nous ne pensons pas
utile de rajouter comme ça a déjà été
fait d'ailleurs à l'époque de Nicolas
Sarkozy des lois
d'exception qui prétendent sous le coup
de l'émotion dire ah là on va mieux
contrôler la situation alors qu'en
vérité nous avons aujourd'hui les outils
juridiques on n pas les outils
juridiques par exemple pour empêcher
quelqu'un de partir hors de France mener
la guerre sainte entre guillemets oui
mais attendez quand euh au nom de quoi
on va le faire sur un soupçon on va dire
nous soupsonnons cette personne parce
qu'il na il a un nom à consonance arabe
et qu'il veut se rendre
en Turquie parce qu'il fréquente
certains sites internet ou qu'on trouve
des armes chez lui si on trouve des
armes chez lui la loi permet de
l'arrêter immédiatement nous n'avons pas
besoin d'une nouvelle loi pour ça donc
nous avons nous avons des nous avons un
dispositif je le répète qui mis en œuvre
peut parfaitement contrôler ces
situations donc on ne change rien on on
n'ajoute pas de texte on met on
metpation lo on renforce s'il faut les
moyens les moyens de nos services de nos
services de police pour réussir à à
appliquer de bonne manière la loi et on
voit bien qu'il en manque il y a eu
encore un cafouillage récent dans tout
le monde partle donc appliquons ce qu'on
ce qu'on sa'est déjà faire nous avons
beaucoup de Mo vous êtes contre
également par exemple la création d'une
incrimination de terrorisme individuel
mais oui parce que nous allons nous
allons nous allons vers vers une nous
sommes en train de de mettre en cause
des principes fondamentaux du droit euh
nous le faisons sous c'est pour ça que
nous avons dit French Patriot Act parce
que nous faisions référence à la loi qui
a été votée après les attentats aux
États-Unis et qui relève de la même
logique c'est-à-dire une logique qui
s'écarte des des règles de Dr fondch par
exemple des jeunes de partir faire le
djihad c'est rogner nos libertés
individuelles mais je répète je répète
nous avons des moyens de de traiter ces
questions là mettons en place des des
politiques ne suffisent pas il ne
suffisent pas oui mais il ne suffisent
pas parce que aujourd'hui d'abord est-ce
que ces dispositifs sont réellement mis
en œuvre ça demande à être à être
vérifié et ensuite je le répète si nous
voulons tarir cette situation il y a des
causes profondément politiques auqueles
il convient de s'attaquer ou oui oui et
et vous encouragez aujourd'hui la
communauté musulmane à exprimer son
rejet de toutes ces thèses et de tous
ces actes mais je crois vous savez moi
je côtoie je côtoie beaucoup de
musulmans euh je vis dans des quartiers
et mes voisins beaucoup sont musulmans
dans le nord de Paris oui dans le nord
de Paris et il suffit de discuter avec
eux
pour qu'ex pour qu'il
[Musique]
l'exprime on fait comme si la communauté
musulmane était dans le silence elle est
parfois dans le silence parce qu'on la
montre du doigt ce sont des imams et le
reeur de la Mosquée de Paris qui le
demand nous
av je pense que tous les citoyens
français devraient marcher ens pour dire
NON terrorisme et non à la guerre non
terrorisme et non à la guerre alors on
va changer de sujet Pierre-Laurent on va
évoquer la politique économique suivie
par le gouvernement que vous contestez
par ailleurs mais ça on le savait déjà
le léger recul du chômage au mois d'août
ne doit pas faire illusion l'absence de
croissance depuis le début de l'année
nous enferme donc dans le chômage de
masse et avec quelle conséquence on le
sait tous avant d'accueillir Catel
prigant de laafp les réformes que
dessine manuel Vals avec la surenchère
du Medef souvent Samia
dechir
un premier ministre de gauche acclamé
par le patronat à l'université d'été du
medf ou au côté d'Angela Merkel en
Allemagne manuel Vals assume sa gauche
décomplexée et tient le même discours
j'aime l'entreprises des entreprises
choyées à qui l'on a promis 40 milliards
d'euros de baisse de charg mais le pacte
de compétitivité ne suffit pas à Pierre
gataz qui Martelle la même recette
contre le chômage nous travaillons pas
assez en France mercredi le patron des
patrons a officialisé des propositions
choc pour créer 1 million d'emplois
suppression de 2 jours fériers
assouplissement des 35 heur salaire
inférieur au SMIC complété par l'État
dans un contrat aidé une longue liste
pour remettre en cause un code du
travail jugé dépassé le modèle social a
a vécu il a bien marché il a très bien
marché P éanglorieuse nous sommes dans
un monde du 21e siècle Tol les syndical
immédiat y compris chez les modérés de
la CFDT devant les député manuel Vals
gêné a dû recadrer le MDEF personne et
je le dis clairement au patronat ne doit
prendre le risque d'affaiblir par je ne
sais quelle provocation et par je ne
sais quelle surenchère l'indispensable
dialogue social à droite certains
applaudissent sans complexe les
propositions de Pierre gataz ce que
propose le MDEF est assez décapant mais
c'est de en fait de diminuer réellement
par un effort de tous le coût du travail
en France qui est le principal obstacle
de notre compétitivité officiellement
les propositions ont été balayées par la
majorité mais certains des proches de
Manuel Vals se disent prêt à étudier
certaines pistes ce ne sont pas des
propositions qui me choquent puisque
encore une fois dans les textes que nous
avons voté comme l'Annie il y a des
aménagements quand l'entreprise et les
salariés le souhaitent le vote dans des
débats internes quand l'entreprise est
en difficulté pour aménager le temps de
travail de la même manière le travail le
dimanche existe déjà sur certains
secteurs tour
soucieux de libéraliser le marché du
travail sans braquer les syndicats le
gouvernement prend soin à chaque
nouvelle mesure évoquée de rappeler que
tout passera par le dialogue social
voilà Catel prigant de la FP nous a
rejoint bonsoir Catel question alors on
l'a entendu le MDEF est à l'offensive
propose l'assouplissement des 35 heur
l'assouplissement du SMIC le la
suppression des jours ferriers pour
l'instant c'est balayé d'un revers de
main de du gouvernement mais on dit à
chaque fois il y a une petite avancée
quand même et le meddeef pourrait de
nouveau gagner ses avancées mais le
meddeef a toujours la même stratégie
c'est-à-dire que un jour il applaudit
manuel Vals et puis le lendemain il lui
en demande encore plus et puis à force
d'aller comme ça on tend toujours un peu
plus le bras et on se fait manger manger
entièrement et le MDEF va continuer il
n'a aucune raison de s'arrêter puisque
pour le moment finalement au bout du
compte en ce moment avec ce gouvernement
il gagne toujours et il obtient toujours
un recul supplémentaire du droit du
travail donc le MDEF va continuer et
tant que le gouvernement fera des
concessions comme il le fait aujourd'hui
sans aucun résultat parce que ce qui est
extraordinaire en plus dans la situation
c'est que le gouvernement ne cesse de
faire des concessions MDEF et les
résultats en terme de lutte contre le
chômage sont inexistant mais est-ce que
tout est à jeté dans les propositions du
meddef est-ce qu'il y a pas une ou deux
propositions est-ce que effectivement
quand ils disent les suppressions des
jours ferriers ce serait 100000 emplois
en plus
ou il y a il y a 5 millions il y a 5
millions chômeurs 5 millions de chômeurs
on nous présente comme une révolution le
fait que le MF nous dit on va créer avec
leur mesure soi-disant 1 million
d'emplois un million d'emplois sur
combien d'années en vérité en rythme de
croisière on a produit sur 5 ans à peu
près 1 millions même quand il y a une
croissance nulle donc en vérité le MDEF
ne propose strictement rien il propose
des des des mesures qui sont uniquement
des marchés de DUP tout le monde sait ce
qui se passera si on supprime des jours
ferriers les entreprises feront
davantage travailler leur salarié actuel
tout le monde le sait alleer aller dans
la grande distribution à qui vous allez
faire croire que supprimer des jour
fériés augmente augmente le nombre de
salariés qui sont embauchés on va faire
un peu faire un peu plus d'heur à des
gens qui sont dans leur très grande
majorité à temps partiel voilà la
situation donc en fait on fait on
dégrade la réalité des propositions du
MF c'est qu'on va dégrader les
conditions de travail de ceux qui
souffrent déjà au travail et qu'en
vérité il continuera d'y avoir tout
toujours autant de gens à la porte de
l'emploi Michel le disait le manque de
croissance nous enferme dans dans le
chômage de masse qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire alors mais comment est-ce que vous
voulez qu'it de la croissance quand le
niveau des salaires ne cesse de baisser
que la demande est totalement à ton
parce qu'on s'attaque sans cesse au
pouvoir d'achat d'un côté et que de
l'autre côté les entreprises à qui ont
distribue de l'argent au lieu d'utiliser
cet argent à investir et à moderniser
l'appareil productif singulièrement les
plus grandes l'utilise à accroître les
dividendes comme l'ont montré
les statistiques de ces de ces derniers
mois donc on est dans un système qui
nous enfonce et en plus qui est tiré
vers le bas par les politiques
d'austérité budgétaire qui dépriment
l'investissement public et on on mène
ces politiques dans toute l'Europe
et l'intégralité de la zone européenne
est dans la difficulté et l'Allemagne
qu'on nous a présenté comme le modèle à
suivre et lui-même maintenant avec des
chiffes de recul qui applaudit les
réformes françaises d'ailleurs Madame
Merkel a trouvé les réformes mais et
pour cause et pourause puisque tant que
nous continuons d'appliquer la feuille
de route du Medef et celle du pacte
budgétaire européen Angela Merkel
applaudit dès demain mais
malheureusement là aussi c'est sans
aucun résultat pour l'UR mais alors que
faut-il faire on change le on change le
système on inverse il faut changer
totalement de logique moi je je crois
que la logique qui consiste à penser
qu'on va restaurer soi-disant de la
compétitivité en écrasant le coût du
travail nous mène à cette situation il
faudrait au contraire un immense effort
de mobilisation des ressources
nationales qui sont très importantes
contrairement à ce qu'on nous dit mais
il faut utiliser ces ressources
nationales à relancer le pouvoir d'achat
de beaucoup trop de gens qui n'arrivent
plus à vivre correctementce que vous
voyez ces ressources considérables quand
on connaît le poid de la dette les déf
par exemple on distribue 40 milliards
d'euros aux entreprises est-ce que à
quoi sert cet argent dans tous les
entreprises il y a des il y a des checs
du cice qui arrivent en ce moment ça
sert à quoi 800 millions d'euros de cice
pour
les grandes entreprises d'intérim
français 1 milliard d'euros de cice pour
les banques françaises à quoi sert cet
argent pour le moment en dehors de
nourrir les logiques financières
actuelles en terme d'emploi à rien du
tout d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup moi je
vais sur le terrain et bien partout les
salariés m'interrogent on a versé un
chèque de 2 millions d'euros à mon
entreprise je discutais avec des des
salarié d'une entreprise verrière près
de de dieep l'autre jours de cela on a
versé 2 millions d'euros à notre
entreprise et nous on continue de
supprimer des emplois dans notre
entreprise et ça les exemples sont
lesion il suffit d'All pe trouver
d'autres exemples de patrons quand même
ils sont pas tous l'image que celle
présente il y a aussi patrons qui
investissent et qui disent grâce au C je
peux passer une mauvaise
période mais bien sûr mais mais mais il
y a il y a des patrons qui qui essayent
d'investir qui essayent de se développer
mais ils disent tous aussi quand vous
discutez avec eux deux autres questions
dont personne ne parle c'est que ils
n'ont pas de de marché ils n'ont pas de
déboucher parce que la situation est
totalement déprimée premièrement il y a
pas de demande et deuxièmement euh il
faudrait interroger la politique de de
crédit des banques je je cite souvent un
exemple ces temps-ci qu'on m'explique
comment BNP
Paribas BNP bar qui est la plus grande
banque française peut écrire à ses
actionnaires au mois d'août personne ne
parle de ça moi je suis très étonné et
qui disent moi j'ai on va pas avoir de
problème qui rassure ses actionnaires on
paiera sans problème l'amende de 6
milliards et demi de dollars que les
Américains viennent d'infliger à cette
banque amende d'ailleurs très discutable
mais bon c'est un autre sujet et par
ailleurs dans cette lettre aux
actionnaires ils disent on va continuer
d'assurer un bénéfice à deux chiffres
pour nos actionnaires mais par contre
quand on demande à BNP Paribas de venir
dans un tour de table pour sauver Alstom
quand on Demand à BNP Paribas de
soutenir une une entreprise qui a besoin
de passer une période difficile quand on
demande à BNP paribba d'être là au côté
des collectivités locales il y a plus
personneors qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
nationalise la blébanque mais je pense
qu'il faudrait constituer un pôle public
bancaire bien plus important que la BPI
actuelle qui est beaucoup trop petite il
faut donc un pôle public bancaire qui
devra comprendre les moyens comme la
Caisse des dépôts et de consignation et
et les moyen de la BPI mais aussi
inclure des grandes banques françaises
actuelles parce que si nous ne
retrouvons pas la maîtrise de ces
ressourcesl effectivement nous ne
pouvons pas financer l'effort de relance
sociale nécessaire alors il y en a qu'on
entend c'est le meddeef d'autres qu'on
entend moins à part pour répondre m ce
sont les syndicats comment
expliquez-vous que les mouvements
sociaux ne partent pas ne des mouvements
sociaux si on veut bien tendre l'oreille
et écouter et aller un peu sur le
terrain il y en a beaucoup il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises où il y a des
mouvements sociaux malheureusement à
chaque fois que des salariés essayent de
de se lever ils sont montrés du doigt
regardez ce qu'on a dit des chemineau
qui essayait de poser une question très
importante pour le pays est-ce qu'on va
investir dans le développement du du
ferroviaire et du fra de ferroviaire
dans les anné à venir est-ce qu'on va
avoir les moyens de le faire on a dit
ils veulent défendre leur leur
prétendu j'all vous parler des pilotes
d' France les pilotes d'Air France c'est
la mais les pilotes d' France POS posent
une bonne question pour l'avenir du
transport aérien c'est est-ce que
l'avenir du du transport aérien c'est
des entreprises lowcost où on va
brader les les les emplois et des
emplois qualifiés pas seulement les
leurs parce que la question posée par
les pilotes est une question qui va
concerner l'ensemble des personnels
d'Air France et probablement il n'y a il
faudrait travailler j'ai pas de leçons à
donner aux salariés d'Air France mais je
pense que les uns et les autres auraient
intérêt à travailler à des convergences
là où certains vont essayer d'opposer il
y avait aussi une contrreemanif d'autres
personnels d'Air France justement disant
nous on fait des efforts pour le
personnel à terre ce sont les pilotes
personnel plus plus aisé plus plus
favorisé dans l'entreprise qui qui
bloque l'entreprise mais parce que
effectivement une des une des des des
des armes entre les mains de ceux qui
veulent mener cette politique c'est de
diviser les salariés entre eux donc il y
a toujours plus défavorisés que vous
parce que les pilotes de France qui ont
de lourdes responsabilités que dont on
respecte évidemment le travail qui gagne
200000 250000 € par an sont les mieux
placés pour dénoncer les risques d'une
dumping social mais demain il y aura si
on fait Transavia Europe il y aura des
pilotes aux commande des avions à qui à
qui cela rend service d'avoir des
pilotes on a on aura des pilotes qui
gagneront qui gagneront beaucoup moins
et qui seront moins qualifiés qualif
c'est ça l'avenir
ah moins moins qualifié alors a autant
qualifié mais moins bien payé bon et et
et vous croyez que c'est une question
qui se pose que pour les pilotes d'Air
France vous connaissez le niveau des
salaires des des gens qui sortent à bac
+ 5 et qui essayent d'aller travailler
dans le public et dans le privé et qui
sont parfois payés 1500 €
allez dans des entreprises même de la
grande distribution aux caisses vous
trouvez des salariés qualifiés qui sont
obligé d'accepter
des donc la déqualification c'est pas
une question qui concerne seulement les
piles France fr km Alexandre Junac dit
que la compagnie peut son salaire
Alexandre Junac lui qui parlecoup
plusieurs centaines il gagne plus que
les pilotes il est déjà il est dans une
autre catégorie lui parce que lui on
pourrait parler des sacrifices qu'il
fait aussi sur son salaire oui je le
connais pas le niveau de son salaire
mais je pense je pense qu'il a rien à
voir avec celui des pilotes ça je me
fais pas d'inquiétude pour lu vous avvez
raison il dit néanmoins que la compagnie
qu'il préside toujours on verra ce qui
se passe puisqu'il a été quand même
lâché par le gouvernement que la
compagnie à France peut mourir demain en
raison de cette grève qui coûte 15 20
millions d'euros par jour de 11 jours
mais mais mais c'est ce système de
dumping social généralisé et qu'on
laisse se développer qu'on organise même
à l'échelle européenne qui tue des
entreprises en permanence c'est ce
système là qui tue qui tue l'emploi qui
tue l'entreprise qui tue la
qualification c'est que on ne conçoit le
développement économique comme que comme
une guerre à outrance entre les
entreprises il faut restaurer un monde
de régulation un monde de coopération un
monde de partage dans le domaine
économique effectivement c'est une autre
règond partage écoutez c'est pas
vraiment comme cela que fonctionne le
monde malheureusement hein mais c'est
bien pour ça que les communistes
proposent de changer ce monde justement
a-udelà des pilotes justement est-ce que
vous comprenez que pourquoi les
mouvements qu'on entend en ce moment ce
sont bon les pilotes mais aussi les
pharmaciens les notaires est-ce que ça
veut dire que le monde ouvrier le monde
salarié est devenu silencieux et
désabusé et ne manifeste plus mais pas
du tout pas du tout moi j'étais
encore hier écoutez j'ai dans la même
journée j'ai dans la même journée été à
une manifestation des femmes de chambre
des grands hôtels parisiens qui se
battent pour leur Sala et qui
n'acceptent pas d'avoir des salaires de
misère alors qu'ell travaill dans des
hôtels de luxe et dans des chaînes qui
sont bourré bourré de pognons ensuite je
effectivement j'ai croisé les les
salariés d'Air France et ensuite je me
suis rendu à une manifestation des
hospitaliers qui manifestent contre les
restructurations hospitalières les
fermetures d'hôpitaux de proximité donc
il y a des des des des travailleurs de
catégories très différentes qui sont
dans l'action mais qui je le répète sont
plus montrer du doigt qu'ils ne sont
soutenus alors vous vous faites le grand
écart quand même he entre effectivement
les femmes de chamb qui sont payés au
lancepierre par des grands palac
parisiens et les pilotes d'Air France
mais parce que je pense que justement la
caractéristique du monde dans lequel
nous sommes c'est que peu à peu on
s'attaque en vérité à l'ensemble des
catégories du salariat ce qui est en
cause en ce moment en France et en
Europe c'est que on veut tirer vers le
bas l'ensemble du salariat dans toutes
ces catégories et moi je refuse ça
d'accord juste un mot Nicolas Sarkozi
est revenu vous l'avez trouvé changé
c'est exactement le même il a suffit de
écouter 5 minutes pour voir que il a il
a fait 2 minutes pour essayer de dire
j'ai changé je suis différent et au bout
de 5 minutes on avait compris que le
même Nicolas Sarkozi était revenu sur
nos écrans et ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que lui par contre il revient euh
40 minutes sur France 2 le dimanche soir
enfin toutes les portes lui sont
ouvertes immédiatement c'est
extraordinaire il a pas perdu tout son
pouvoir en tout cas vous avvez pas écrit
au CSA vous on pourrait le faire on
pourrait le faire mais mais c'est vrai
que c'est bon c'est il y a quelque chose
d'assez choquant quand on sait comment
il faut parfois se se battre je ne parle
pas Public Sénat mais comment il faut
parfois se battre pour pouvoir
s'exprimer sur une grande chaîne de
télévisionci vous êtes largement invité
souvent et on est toujours content de
vous donner la parole Pierre Laurent
merci Catel allez pierre inarnaau va
venir maintenant on va parler des
sénatoriales donc dimanche un petit
rappel d'abord quel est donc l'enjeu de
cette élection qui pourrait devrait se
traduire par un basculement du Sénat à
droite que restera-t-il de cette
parenthèse à gauch piur vous allez nous
le dire 3 ans durant lesquels et ben on
vous a quand même plus souvent vu du
côté de la droite dans l'opposition
Faustine
saint-jeogè il n'y a que 178 sièges à
prendre à la Haute Assemblée mais ils
sont 1733 candidats à en rêver un record
un nombre jusqu'ici jamais atteint dans
quelques jours c'est donc la moitié du
Sénat qui sera renouvelé 59 départements
qu collectivités d'outrem et 6 des 12
sièges de la circonscription des
Français établis hors de France un
renouvellement partiel au mode de
scrutin particulier le suffrage
universel indirect dimanche
87534 grands électeurs iront voter pour
élire les sénateurs pour un mandat de 6
ans le collège électoral dans chaque
département est composé en réité de
grands élus locaux les maire un certain
nombre de conseillers municipaux et dans
les grandes villes de délégués désignés
par les conseils municipaux on ajoute à
cela les conseillers généraux les
conseillers régionaux et les députés les
élections sénatorial mélange deux types
de scrutin le scrutin majoritaire à deux
tours dans les départements qui élisent
seulement un ou deux sénateurs est élu
celui qui obtient au premier tour la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
le scrutin majoritaire concerne ici 59
sièges autre mode de scrutin la
représentation proportionnelle dans les
départements où sont au moins élus trois
sénateurs dans un département vous avez
x sièg de sénateurs à pourvoir vous avez
un certain nombre de listes et bien on
attribue les sièges des sénateurs en
proportion du nombre de voies obtenus
par chaque liste et là cela concerne 119
sièges même si rien n'est joué il est
fort probable que le Sénat bascule à
droite cont tenu des élections municipal
de mars dernier la vague bleue pourrait
donc s'emparer également du Sénat
finalement la plus forte incertitude
concerne la présidence de la haute
assemblée qui pour accéder au plateau
voilà on a les choses bien en tête
maintenant he grâce à Marie bremo
bonsoir preinn question bonsoir oui mes
questions effectivement est-ce qu'il y a
encore des chances selon vous pour que
la gauche gagne conserve le Sénat à
l'issu du renouvellement de dimanche ça
va être difficile on le sait depuis
depuis le la fin du printemps parce que
les élections municipales ont dégradé le
rapport de force au profit de de la
droite mais il y a encore des
incertitudes dans beaucoup de
départements parce que une partie des
grands électeurs qui sont notamment des
notamment dans les départements ruraux
sont des électeurs dont on sait qu'
peuvent encore modifier leur opinion et
les les les campagnes menées par nos
candidats dans les départements montre
que des choses peuvent bouger jusqu'à
dimanche ouais même si quand même aucun
enjeu sur le terrain que ce soit la
réforme territoriale les rythmes
scolaires la baisse des donations
publiques rien ne va en faveur de la
gauche quand même sur le terrain quand
on suit un peu la campagne territoriale
la réforme territoriale crée un très
grand trouble chez les chez les élus
locaux parce que il ils ne comprennent
pas et singulièrement les élus
territoriaux issus de la gauche ne
comprennent pas le sens de ces réformes
donc c'estav notamment le fait que le
gouvernement é changé trois fois de pied
de cap sur cette réforme territoriale
oui trois fois le fait qu'on a appris a
il y a il y a 15 jours à peine seulement
la date des élections en mars prochain
enfin tout ça donne le sentiment d'une
très grande improvisation et surtout met
les les élus locaux dans beaucoup d'unc
ctitude sur la manière dont ils vont
pouvoir exercer leur mandat dans les
dans les mois et les années à venir mais
c'est une question sur laquelle nos
candidats discutent beaucoup avec les
élus locaux et il y en a qui qui sont
très sensible à la à la place que nous
pouvons tenir demain dans le Sénat
justement pour essayer à gauche de de
tenir un cap qui soit un cap sérieux sur
ces questions de la réforme territoriale
alors c'est vrai que la gauche est
partie assez divisée hein pour ces
élections sénatoriales il y a des listes
du Front de gauche il y a des listes
Europe Écologie Les vert il y a des
listes socialistes cette gauche divisée
c'est ce qui va faire c'est ce qui va
vous faire perdre le Sénat la dernière
fois aussi il y avait aussi beaucoup de
départements dans lequel nous avions des
listes front gauche il beauoup de
départements où il y avait des listes
d'union il y avait les deux
effectivement mais nous étions dans une
autre situation et c'est sûr que à la
fois la situation politique nationale et
les débats sur la réforme territoriale
ont conduit probablement ont contribué à
la à la situation dans la laquelle nous
abordons ces élections mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de listes à droite donc ouais
il y a quand même moins moins de
divisions à droite cette fois-ci qu'à
gauche on va on va voir on regardera
dimanche soir on va regarder dimanche
soir on peut toujours avoir
effectivement des des surprises à
l'issue des des élections sénatoriales
ce que vous disiez à l'instant est
intéressant vous espérez donc finalement
profiter du désamour des grands
électeurs de gauche vis-à-vis du
gouvernement vis-à-vis du Parti
socialiste vous espérez que des listes
du Front de Gauche puissent gagner des
sièges il y a beaucoup des de grands
électeurs qui s'interrogent
effectivement et qui cherchent le vote
le plus utile à leur conviction et je
pense que beaucoup de nos candidats sont
en harmonie avec ces préoccupation et
vous pensez gagner des sièges euh
écoutez nous avons cinq sénateurs et
sénatrices renouvelables enfin dans dans
cette partie là c'està nous sommes 21
nous en avons cinq qui sont
renouvelables les les les cinq sont dans
des situations compliquées pour les
raisons qu'on disait mais nous espérons
en garder une une bonne partie vous CR
en en fait donc hein oui c'est ben c'est
un risque qui concerne qui concerne
évidemment toute la gauche il y a des
départements la situation est difficile
mais il y en a peut-être d'autres où il
y aura des surprises il y en a eu la
dernière fois il peut y en avoir aussi
cette fois-ci d'ord est-ce que Pierre
Laurent le Parti communiste et le Front
de gauche n'ont pas contribué à
affaiblir le Sénat en rejetant les
derniers textes importants je pense
notamment au budget dernier taxe
important de la législature euh des
rejets qui sont faits avec des majorités
de circonstances un peu aléatoires mais
nous ne portons pas la responsabilité de
cette situation nous nous étions partis
quand le Sénat est passé à gauche pour
que le Sénat vote des lois de gauche et
je rappelle que la première année quand
nous étions dans l'opposition nous avons
voté
ensemble toute une série de lois
malheureusement ce cours là c'est c'est
interrompu et dégradé progressivement
tout simplement parce que c'est pas nous
qui avons changé le cours des choses
c'est que le gouvernement a mis le cap
sur des politiques qui n'avaient rien à
voir avec ce qu'on attendait d'une
majorité de gauche j'entendais tout àhe
avec la droite et affaiblir le
gouvernement non mais nous n'avons
jamais voté avec la droite quand on sait
écouter les débats et les motivations
motivationé ensem non nous nous avons
exprimé notre opposition un certain
nombre de
textesve avec des arguments avec des
arguments qui étaient quasiment à chaque
fois à l'exacte opposé de ceux de la
droite donc il n'y a pas d'ambigé ça
c'est un mauvais procès qu'on nous fait
pour essayer d'étouffer le débat à
gauche mais par contre quand j'entends
tout à l'heure dans votre reportage Luc
Carvounas ouis à propos des propositions
du M dire bah oui sénateur du
valdeemarne dire bah oui on a fait des
choses pas si mal et pas si loin du MF
la pruve la ni effectivement Laan nous
avons rejeté la ni quand nous étions au
Sénat parce que c'est une loi
d'inspiration d'inspiration libérale
issu quand même de de du débat de la
négociation sociale oui mais son résult
fruit
ul des dros la GAE n' jamais été dans
son histoire élu pour faire reculer les
droits sociaux nous sommes là pour les
faire progresser alors je vous écoute je
pense à la phrase de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
franç Hollande c'est pire que Nicolas
Nicolas Sarkozy vous la reprenez à votre
compte je je ne prononce pas cette
phrase pour une raison simple c'est que
je ne souhaite à aucun prix le retour de
Nicolas Sarkozi et que je pense que si
Nicolas Sarkozi revenait au pouvoir il
continuerait encore à aggraver dans la
même direction donc le problème n'est
pas celui c'est pire le problème c'est
que bien sûr d'ailleurs il suffit de
lire le programme de la droite quand le
gouvernement actuel veut faire 50
milliards d'économie de dépenses publiqu
la droite écrit dans son programme
qu'elle veut en faire 100 ou 130 donc
évidemment que ce serait ce serait bien
pire quand l'autre jour j'étais dans un
débat télévisé par sur votre chaîne
François berou jette sur la table le
code du travail en disant qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce truc ça sert plus à rien
faut le supprimer il a pas dit ça tout à
fait il a dit c'est c'est gros comme un
betin on peut enlever quelques pages oui
oui c'est ça c'est exactement ça c'est
les pages où sont écrit un peu trop de
réglementation sociale favorable au
salariés on comprend bien l'esprit du
coup donc du coup à l'automne là 2014
quand vont arriver devant le Parlement
et devant le Sénat le projet loi de
finance pour 2015 et le projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale vous
allez sans doute Pierre Laurent rejeter
ces deux textes et donc voter avec la
droite sénatoriale mais écoutez on fera
ce que on verra ce que fera la droite
sénatoriale qui peut-être comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure mais nous nous
allons combattre les les textesous nous
arrive pour le moment et pour cause euh
nous n'allons pas accepter des textes
qui par exemple en matière de projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale vont faire gravement reculer le
niveau de protection sociale donc nous
mais nous allons comme d'habitude comme
d'habitude nous allons proposer des
amendements nous allons essayer de
modifier ces textes essayer de les
améliorer et il on verra si le
gouvernement nous entend on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il refuse
systématiquement d'entendre nos
propositions et que ça contribue à la
situation actuelle qui est une une
impasse économique et une défaite
politique pour ce gouvernement à
l'occasion de ces élections sénatoriales
on peut lire dans la presse beaucoup de
papiers qui dénoncent le train de vie du
Sénat il y a une espèce de Sénat baching
en ce moment dans qu même L'Express
demander la suppression du Sénat VO
est-ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
d'abord est-ce qu'il faut supprimer le
Sénat et est-ce que ce Sénat bashing est
justifié selon vous il y aurait beaucoup
de réformes moi je m'inquiète de ce
climat que j'entends comme vous j'ai vu
d'ailleurs beaucoup de journalistes
m'interroger dans ce sens-là
parce que mais mais mais en vérité parce
que c'est pas contrô le Sénat seulement
c'est que il y a des gens qui ont l'air
de s'inquiéter de la présence d'élus en
général al il y a trop d'élus locaux le
Sénat ne sert à rien tout ça mais
faisons si on suit tous ces gens-là
retournons à la monarchie nous avons un
président de la République et puis les
autres institutions parlementaires et
les institutions locales ne sont que des
choses superflu et quand on regarde dans
le détail on s'aperçoit qu' un peu la
situation que vous dénonciez il y a un
instant je vous rappelle hein vous criti
le fonctionnement de la République oui
mais mais
elle la République doit être
profondément transformée mais il
faudrait aller dans le sens d'e d'un
accroissement des rôles du Parlement pas
dans une diminution et il faudrait
peut-être changer les modes de scrutin
pour aller vers une meilleure
représentation il y a avec la
proportionnelle il y a beaucoup de
choses à changer évidemment qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses à changer mais
sûrement pas en disant il y a trop
d'élus dans ce pays et ça sert à rien on
sort de TR années de présidence de
gauche ici au Sénat est-ce que vous avez
peut-être des regrets sur des forme qui
aurait pu avoir lieu ici au Sénat et qui
n'ont pas été fait bien sûr beaucoup de
regrets et nous nous avions nous avions
je citer des exemples précis nous avions
je le répète avant dans la première
année du Sénat nous avons adopté
ensemble ici la première année de gauche
en 2011 donc c'est le gouvernement était
lui de droite à ce moment-là nous avons
adopté des lois ensemble la majorité de
gauche du Sénat sur le travail du
dimanche et sur beaucoup d'autres choses
par exemple on a voté une loi sur le
travail du dimanche positive ensemble et
bien aujourd'hui on risque d'aller vers
la législation par ordonnance pour au
contraire libéraliser encore le travail
du dimanche donc le le Sénat de gauche
n'a pas fait le travail qu'il aurait pu
faire s'il avait été écouté par le
gouvernement il y avit dans la réforme
de l'institution elle-même aussi 3
années de présidence de gauche ici
beaucoup regrettent peut-être que que
les liges n'ai pas suffisamment bougé
pour faire évoluer l'institution don
l'image dégrade aussi dans l'opinion
public mais parce que le le le le
gouvernement a c'est s coulé a joué le
jeu d'institution présidentielle
présidentialisé au maximum et que tout
ça dégrade effectivement le rôle du
Parlement et et et on montre du doit à
ce moment-là le Parlement mais c'est le
fonctionnement des institutions qui ne
convient pas par
exemple l'essentiel de l'initiative
législative continue d'être entre les
mains du gouvernement malgré le partage
de l'ordre du jour oui un tout petit
partage quelques parlementaire mais en
vérité il faudrait qu'au moins la moitié
de l'initiative législative revienne au
parlementairire et non pas au
gouvernement est-ce que on vous écoute
vous avez signé l'appel de jeanluc
Mélenchon pour une 6e république je je
suis favorable à la 6e république est-ce
que vous avez signé son appel parce
qu'il réunit des signatures diverses de
personnalit pas signé l'app l'appel de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et l'appel à la
constitution d'un nouveau mouvement moi
je suis entièrement engagé totalement
nouveau il veut révolutionner aussi les
partis politiques ve d' S
mais je je je je regarde tout ça avec
intérêt moi je suis engagé dans ce
combat pour la 6e république et je mène
ce combat avec le Parti communiste et
avec le Front de gauche et je pense que
le Front de gauche qui en a fait un des
thèmes de sa bataille présidentielle
doit continuer à mener ce combat là
donc je je je je devais pas ajouter un
autre mouvement à cela pour mener ce
combat de la 6e république mais la 6e
république je suis engagé à fond pour
l'idée d'une 6e république du leadership
alors pour la 6e République entre méench
mais non mais ça n'est pas une guerre du
leadership les gens les gens se moquent
de tout ça il y a plein de gens qui
parlent maintenant de l'idée de la 6e
République nous ne sommes pas les seuls
ni Jean-Luc Mélenchon ni moi-même il y a
beaucoup de gens qui mais bien sûr nous
nous voyons nous nous voyons
régulièrement et et nous étions ensemble
à la Fête de l'Humanité il y a quelques
jours voilà c'est vre dernière sortie
commune dernière petite question très
rapide vendredi dernier berc a publié le
détail de de la réserve parlementaire
pour les sénateurs en une phrase est-ce
que c'est un système obsolète selon vous
qu'il faut supprimer 54 milli je pense
c'est je pense que c'est un système qui
devrait être modifié oui parce que il
est je je sais pas je m'interroge
là-dessus en tout cas parce que je crois
que par exemple on assiste à un
phénomène curieux on diminue les les
subventions aux associations dans le
cadre de l'austérité budgétaire et alors
toutes les associations nous écrivent
des des centaines de lettres j'en reçois
comme probablement tous les sénateurs
qui nous demandent de les financer grâce
à la réserve parlementaire nous ne
pouvons pas le faire contrairement parce
que l' nous av Chun est petite même si
elle paraî grosse au total mais on voit
bien que c'est un système pervers donc
il faut vous interroger oui oui oui
c'est pas c'est pas un système qui est
très très merci merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui Monsieur Merci pine bien sûr
vous serez présente on se rrouve
effectivement diman sur la chne dimanche
soir pour la soirée des éou même dès
11h3 du matin parce que parfis ça va
vite he les résultatsou ou un premier
tour en fin de mi-journée effectivement
an on continue jusqu'à minuit dimanche
rendez-vous dimanche soir donc pour ce
scrutin sénatorial merci à tous bonsoir
à très
vite